an accused child killer grabs a homicide
detective's gun
new video first obtained by the i-team
shows how that situation
could have turned deadly thank you for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez the i-team has been
leading coverage on this tragic story
vanessa murphy is here with more on
evidence at the center of the case and
vanessa this video landed terrell rhodes
with even more charges right
yeah terrell rhodes faces a murder
charge and now additional charges
including attempted murder
after he grabbed the homicide
detective's gun
metro police say he had just confessed
to killing two-year-old amari nicholson
he likely knew he was headed to jail
this is terrell rhodes inside an
interview room
one hand is cuffed to the table he tries
to slip his hand
out metro police say he had just
admitted to beating amari nicholson to
death
and burying his body and he drew this
map
to show where
detectives come back in the room to calm
him down
and he pulls the gun from detective opal
deeds holster
she and another detective struggled to
get the loaded firearm back
two other officers entered the room
about a minute after he took the gun
rhodes appears to be restrained
the next day may 12 investigators found
amari's body near paradise and twain
the i-team obtained photos presented to
the grand jury as evidence
one which we've chosen not to air shows
that the toddler was buried in his
footsie pajamas
this photo shows exactly where amari's
remains were found
this was after a community search for
amari for a week
rhodes previously claimed to eight news
now that a mystery woman
took the child while his girlfriend
amari's mother was
out of town what's really sickening is
that people is
making assumptions thinking that i have
something to do with it that
i have heard
manipulated in some way the 27 year old
has since declined the i-team's request
for an interview grab the cop's gun will
you relax
the i-team has learned that metro policy
allows
officers to be armed in an interview
room when there are
two or more officers present the
department also tells me the critical
incident review team is examining the
incident with a focus on
policy tactics and training the findings
will be used to evaluate current
processes and make
future recommendations the head of the
police union also sent me a statement
saying
this shows officers do everything they
can to preserve a life
and highlights the lengths suspects are
willing to go
his full statement at eight newsnow dot
com